oh [__]
New Year's Day everybody's [__]
resting we're already plotting our
[__] takeover you understand me like
the [__] Koreans we don't sleep
[__] pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier this plane is going [__]
straightjacket it's marijuana
legalization day and that's got nothing
to do with me understand me
it's got nothing
Happy New Year [__] you uncle
Joey here ready to rock ready to take
over you understand me
nice little [__] hibernation I
haven't seen you guys in five days I
didn't forget about you
I just been plotting plot in 2018 I'm
gonna take these [__] down and
let him know what I'm [__] around you
understand me take them down and we're
not [__] around happy new years
[__] uncle Joey here I love you
[__] four star there's gonna be
our year write your goals do your
push-ups and starts today you understand
me
whatever happened last week whatever
happened last month whatever happened
last year who gives a Frenchman's [__]
don't talk to it but this you don't
understand they would meet my macaroni
sell gives a [__]
waste your time with a [__] psycho
therapist the psychiatrist grab your
dick Smith sniff your fingers it's 2018
how much smaller like these [__]
[__] kick in the [__] ass no much
longer with the [__] how much longer
this one at this decision I woke up one
day when I was [__] 40 how much
longer man let these [__] jerk-offs
make a [__] [__] out of me not
anymore [__] would taken with Tosh
understand me either they give it to us
we [__] take it that's what it's all
about the Joey what's with the [__]
intent see a beatin if I wanted Anthony
Robbins I woulda got the app I know
let's smoke some [__] reefer listen to
me today I got dosey doe look at these
containers I got patrol I got [__]
kryptonite I got [__] strawberry
cheesecake now I'm going over there
right now to drop another [__] that's
it I'm gonna buy them out today all the
28% weeds or the [__] edibles it's
over I got my cash a like Pablo you
understand me
enjoy what do we got this week we got
nothing we got dick these people still
walking around I saw my room five four
new you who gives a [__] that's over
with what are we gonna do now that's the
plan of attack the art of war how you
gonna make it now man without a plan
there's not a man Nietzsche said that
[__] and after John Gotti said before he
sent those four jerk box to shoot broke
last alarm oh you understand me but
anyway that's that and this is us what
are we gonna do how we gonna make 2019
are you that's a you should be frigging
actually let the rest of these [__]
[__] watch football do your [__] I'm
already at I've been up since 601 when
your [__] and stabbed my mother [__] in
the neck oh we gonna smoke next 40 picks
we do it strawberry cheesecake what's in
this [__] container I got nothing but
[__] love for you [__]
understand me from Dante Kazemi - [__]
it the Holloway brothers down in
Secaucus running things sending me a
family picture last night it brought a
[__] tear to my eye
Dody isn't what I was us were you
[__] that eating tormenta them and
[__] hold them in the kitchen while
[__] Roger robbed them in the [__]
bedroom the good old days [__] oh
yeah
she's a sleeper I had put some away a
couple nights when I got up in the
middle of night to [__] take a piss I
couldn't sleep I took to it so this
[__] strawberry shortcake forget
about it I was in [__] Jupiter Mars
and Venus all on one [__] trip I had
a [__] drink coconut water just to
hydrate you follow me Saturday night
working out with uncle Joey at the ice
house I'm back how many Y's it's all
over
I took a breather you need to take a
breather it's been 25 [__] years it
took three we [__] breather from
stand-up didn't watch it didn't go to
clubs didn't talk to these [__]
but guess what I'm gonna call them all
this morning and straighten all these
[__] out and tell them what I
got on my mind cuz that's all that
matters I don't give a [__] what you got
on your mind it's what you got on your
[__] mind that matters understand
sounds little [__] up but it's not
what they give a [__] you know I don't
give a [__] about nobody ever listen
you're coming out the box like a house
and change you follow me you don't give
a [__] joy which would be abatement turn
this on sweetest emotion [__] refund
let's do this [__] do this [__] we did
this very short date let's try this
[__] kryptonite look at this little
baby stem I'm gonna [__] spark that
pregnant I love this reefer you
understand me here take your booze and
your [__] opiates and all that [__]
then shove it up your ass till the end
of time this is the champion right here
you follow me you smoke a little dope
eat an apple nobody bothers you
the beach was great with my family man
my daughter had a great time that's all
that matters
I'm gonna come to that [__] I don't give
a [__] I just give my wife the [__]
credit card go who gives a [__] it's for
the kid you know she had a great time
she's in her room playing with [__]
Barbies I got a bow and arrow I'm gonna
go out here for a little while shoot a
[__] bow and arrow and I said that's
my bet we got a podcast later o'clock
tonight make sure you're there if you're
trying to get things together in your
life we're gonna give you the [__]
road map number two I'm at the ice house
Saturday night so really sold out I
think I don't [__] know but that on
the 5th on the 18th or the 15th through
the 18th 18th I am vade [__] Austen
[__] get ready to [__] rock ok
Texas which word all started for me
because let me tell you something 80% of
the Tommy I did back 20 years ago was
doing I was living in [__] Texas I
was living in [__] Houston so I'm
coming back to Austin with a [__]
vengeance I did this my only Texas
appearance this year I think about two
nights in Dallas later on Andy I'm not
sure but Austin this is it [__]
barbecue [__] Papa dolls [__] Chuy's
I'm coming down crystal and Bobby
Shannon [__] ready to rock we got him
on point
Obie Spooky's down there holding down
the fort and [__]
nice it's nice when I can just sit out
here with you guys
no pressure we smoke my [__] family
and then you go back inside and you
[__] watch TV or whatever funky with
them on
so we smoke this that this let's try
this [__] patron this patron is that
it's [__] that Joe listen to me it's
[__] dead okay usually give a
shout-out to perennially scared a
meteors gonna the only media you're
gonna need to be scared of this going up
your [__] ass or you'll be out for
two [__] years you won't know what it
is the best edible yeah bad well this is
called the [__] animal look at this
[__] thing
that's [__] patron right there you
think I'm gonna show up with some shitty
weave here [__] on a Monday
morning and Lee is there to respect [__]
you people didn't keep dealing with me
you think I'm not sure I enjoyed your
mug weed I show up with nothing but
[__] debt well how does it taste what
he said hybrid it's it's it's a big dick
wit that's all you need to worry about
oil we [__] Joe genius when it comes
to refit just suck my dick
I want that t understand me but I want
something to give me energy
I think microdot less than shut the [__]
up
that's the one that killed the [__]
ship right there but anyway you know I
love you [__] we're all my own
I'm going and do bas Rutten mouthpiece I
gotta get a few plane tickets I'm gonna
hang out with the family module it'll
[__] worked out I got a little weed
store and guess what podcast 8 o'clock
time my [__] be there or be [__]
square get your [__] together we're
gonna start the year off with a [__]
bang boom Oh [__] Tonya Isis is done
Isis ain't done I saw two [__]
on the 405 with firecrackers
Isis ain't gonna understand anyway you
know I love you [__] with all
my heart this is your year
what ever happened listen this is your
year focus you want to get out of this
[__] mess we do this together get the
[__] out of this mess tell this
[__] tell this to kiss her debt
to get away from you and let's start a
no it's a whole new set of rules [__]
but it's your rules it's not their rules
it's your [__] rules never gonna buy
their rules it's your [__] rules you
follow me I'm not telling you to break
rules I'm telling you that you're the
Captain Kirk to the [__] enterprise
and at the end of the day you're the one
that has to pay for groceries and you at
the [__] supermarket so [__] all
these [__] grab your balls look
in the mirror and say what the [__]
happened what the [__] happened this is
gonna change today in the smoke some
weed I'm gonna write my [__] goals
and 2018 is gonna be a [__] breeze
it's like stealing when you put your
mind to it
stay black uncle Joey loves you don't
take [__] from nobody it's 2018 you
understand me enough is [__] enough
these [__] are singing nothing
compared to what they're gonna see for
me this year so get ready strap on a
seat belt without you [__] I
got nothing like a dick you understand
me
you guys are my [__] backbone you
guys know I'm not [__] around and you
ain't [__] around
with you you're with me and they wanna
be with us have a great day hungry cat
tell your mother you love her and get
out there stab a [__]
it's your year [__] be able to
[__] whatever I don't know I didn't
talk a little Chinese people yet this
morning I love you stay black I see you
kind of suffice tonight if I could be
there or be square he might start early
I see what time [__] [__] gets back
and we'll get this party started all
right have a great day uncle Joey loves
you stay black
focus [__] em for you they didn't come
on my till a beating a liar